foreign
[Music]
who really gives a crap about law isn't
this the most bizarre delivery
[Music]
Donald Trump Jr
delivered a manic episodes
this prosecution isn't based on facts
or the law
how would he know them they'll all be
damned the Constitution be damned your
rights beat Dan because yeah when you
hate America what difference does it
make junior is just ranting
uncontrollably the hot take on Twitter
was that these guys are trying to do
this this is the hot stupid take on
Twitter over the weekend like the
dumbest take ever ever
I've never seen Junior like this and
I've seen Junior pretty hopped up full
shavik style I've never seen Junior like
this and I've seen Junior pretty hopped
up
I don't know I've never seen Junior like
this and I've seen Junior pretty hopped
up Bolshevik style I've never seen
Junior like this and I've seen Junior
pretty hopped up pure witch hunter I'm
worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my Lane
you're like
um
getting rid of the machine felting down
and turned him into prison bars I'm not
a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers the
lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machine
just pillows who did this attack who did
the Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said she said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
Madison you're not giving my phone I
said arrest me I've done nothing wrong
he said no we're not gonna arrest you I
swear you can do
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you some Phyllis I'm worried about
my legs I've tried for getting rid of
the machines Okay Melt them down and
turn them into prison bars
pillow all right thanks Mike take care
okay
great to be here
[Music]
on
for the people that don't know if you
can take a quick moment got a massive
YouTube channel and we got billions of
views online
all right sorry everybody we don't have
time for that because Trump's lawyer is
ranting let's listen he has nothing to
say other than what his array said on
the road
we talked a little bit about how we were
flexing the converter
how does that play in the appeal the
fact that
yeah I think it's a an inconsistent
verdict right and um it's something that
obviously will be another issue for
appeal but from the issue for the
appeals were late really months ago when
when things like you know Donald Trump's
attempt to have the dress tested for DNA
after they sent it into a lab
I think that's something that was
important um the fact that the Reed
Hoffman the Democratic planeteer
you know who Miss Carol was not candid
about when she testified initially on
the earth in her deposition
um you know that should come into this
case the Access Hollywood
for 403 that balances out inflammatory
practitioner things and that certainly
was one of them so but there's plenty of
issues to appeal and uh look that's what
happens right you know we're we're in
one sense gratified and I know some
people in this Camp are very happy
um that you know the great flame was
rejected but you know I'm not and uh I
am happy about that certainly but I'm
not happy that he was not liable for
anything whatsoever because on this I've
decided I think we should have been
career you know he's strong he's uh he's
ready to to move forward
um he wants to fight this honestly he's
ready to fight um again he was
successful in one appeal before the
second Circle judge Kaplan on Carol vs
Trump and he thinks it's gonna be
successful on the second one but he's
planning you know he's got a
[Music]
what a scrum
results
all right let's see if we can get a
different view of all this somewhere in
here you know
there's a woman in the background
yelling sexual predator and rapist for
people wondering
could we get a proper mic on this guy
what is short of the cases but again
what people have been saying is that in
New York you just can't prepare products
your boss is a kind of word
told them
wow
emotions running high as you can see
I'd like to actually hear what the
lawyer is saying but it's not clear that
any of oh let's see this one as we were
hearing uh clearly some vulgarity there
from someone uh just not far from Joe
jackapina former there was vulgarity
we're speaking with reporters if things
calm down let me know guys we'll go back
there but I think so the NBC's get your
ABC's getting away from it because of
the vulgarity we're trying to hear the
vulgarity if you can imagine uh okay it
looks like takapina is rapping and then
soon we're going to hear from the
lawyers from E Gene Carroll people are
running
see what's going on looks like it's
getting very escalated here
[Music]
everybody media is running now they're
trying to get back
to where we don't know this is a Reuters
feed
this is wild wild stuff
the profanity lace tirade continues
which I love personally
guys
watch your step guys
let's be careful backing up this is
Trump's lawyer watch your steps we'll go
through all the details when there's a a
lull in this if there is one yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the Reuters feed this is
Trump's lawyers trying to kind of
retreat here's a Washington Post Feed
and as you can see it's very very
similar here is a challah bread oh
that's interesting I like that
um NBC News is in a break and Newsmax is
in a break so right now we're we're sort
of watching The Retreat of Trump's uh
Trump's lawyer here
good
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I presume that media cameras
will now get reset to hear from E Gene
Carroll's lawyers if you're just joining
us failed former president Donald Trump
has not been found liable for rape but
has been found liable for sexual assault
and defamation and has been ordered to
pay Eugene Carroll five million dollars
doesn't seem like a lot but okay
um and we've just heard from Trump's
lawyer Joe takapina to the extent that
we could even hear from him they are now
retreating we are expecting to hear from
Eugene Carroll's lawyers momentarily oh
I just made a bunch of them before sorry
would you just make a quick commentation
please
watch your back watch your back
I got my shot watch your back apparently
a very long walk for Joe takapina to his
car
you're back
don't do this
is real just be careful backing up
all right FedEx continuing to deliver
campaign guys so I don't think so
many expletives shouted including
um sexual your clients a sexual predator
your clients are rapist that sort of
thing
all right so I'm guessing he's very
close to his car at this point
um and then e Gene Carroll's lawyers
still expected to give some kind of a
press conference they're going to appeal
so this is certainly not the end we'll
look at the details in a moment
just be careful backing up
big big thank you to Jason sickmeyer and
Catherine lay I really appreciate that
you signed up on my website we continue
to see all sorts of different liability
against Trump the coupon code remains
indicted and I welcome everybody using
that also big thanks to everybody who
has been uh subscribing via twitch Prime
New Hampshire fog and zoink noise Billy
Carpenter ghost rooster just so many
great people tool moo and New Hampshire
fog with a gift hold my kitties all
these different people that looks like
seven putting us at nine we're gonna be
here looking at all of the details it
looks like Homeland Security Police is
now retreating we're going to get set
back up for the E Gene Carroll press
conference momentarily and and I expect
it to be quite outrageous so here we go
we are standing by now this was a civil
verdict ladies and gentlemen and we're
going to actually let's just look at
that now while we have a moment
uh jury sides with writer who says that
Trump sexually abused her six men and
three women found Donald Trump liable
for sexually abusing and defaming the
writer E Gene Carroll but rejected her
rape accusation rejected her rape
accusation the Manhattan jury determined
yes liability for sexual abuse yes then
he defamed her and she has been awarded
five million dollars in Damages Will
trump ever pay it who the hell knows
um the federal jury of six men and three
women said um that Trump did commit
defamation when he posted a statement to
Troth Central calling her a complete con
job a hoax and a lie Trump has already
responded on truth
where is my truth hold on a second and
we will bend men that's not here it is
truth essential Trump posting in all
caps I have absolutely no idea who this
woman is this verdict is a disgrace a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time Bigger Than The Witch Trials
then going on to say in all caps very
unfair trial so that is Trump's feeling
about it I want to say a huge thank you
to S Prez for gifting 50 twitch Prime
subscriptions I love it thank you s Prez
we continue to stand by for a press
conference from E Gene Carroll's
attorneys
indeed Espress is the top gifter of all
time on Twitch with
3686 gifted subscriptions also big thank
you to Desiree Delong who just signed up
yeah that Stephen K Bannon has now gone
after me uh he interviewed
so um Steve Gannon played my clip on it
I'm going to show you this this is
Bonker stuff I wouldn't let children see
this it's okay and then he went on to
attack me check this out that it's not
just a difference of opinion it's not
it's it's it's something much more
pernicious and more than that okay we're
gonna that's that's brother that's
brother Dave Pacman that's my brother
right there folks uh he's got a a show
and that's his and I could say the same
about you Steve analysis and we're doing
this as a teaching exercise many of you
remember that interview
from a couple of weeks ago but we also
played the Liberty Council who came on
afterwards and and talked about this is
a real thing it's not right but you see
how the left
what they want to do immediately
they don't want to dress they never want
to talk about what the thing is they
never want to talk about what the issue
is they all they always want to um uh do
a ender my my girlfriend does say it's
pervy
um but you know at this point who knows
what that means who knows what that
means
uh okay
and so do we do we know if we have an
active feed outside the geez a lot of
things I think it must have been a
temporary glitch that's all thanks to
Katherine Williams for signing up at
joinpakwin.com very much appreciate that
uh we are going to look very strongly at
everything that's going I I'm getting
hit with a million different messages
from people about different things but
everything seems fine to be perfectly
Frank everything seems fine okay will I
be covering the town hall Trump's Town
Hall tomorrow so I have been advised
that the that CNN is going to go very
very very hard from a copyright
standpoint so my plan tomorrow night
which is the night of Trump's Town Hall
my plan is to do a pre-show a pre-show
and then we'll go we'll go off the air
when the actual Town Hall starts our
YouTube rep and everybody told us you
will get taken down CNN is going super
hardcore it's not worth risk okay so
that's going to be the plan tomorrow
we're going to do a pre-show for the
town hall and then uh you know we'll
we'll just cover it on the Thursday show
I think that's that's really all we're
going to be able to do that's the that's
the CNN Town Hall uh situation okay well
listen it looks like this is it
um it looks like this is the news Trump
owes 5 million to e Gene Carroll he will
appeal and that's going to be it so a
very abbreviated live stream today I
guess it's all over as far as I know the
town hall is still on but there are
people in the chat saying it's not
happening I will investigate thank you
for joining me and let's now get that
new pbd song which I had to cut off for
everybody okay check this out this is
beautiful
[Music]
come on
for the people that don't know if you
can take a quick moment got a massive
YouTube channel you got billions of
views online
[Music]
[Applause]
like the fact that us has liked more
today
[Music]
seriously
seriously keep going what are you
talking about keep going what are you
talking about that's insane
failure
[Music]
I think you're missing the pressure
[Applause]
[Music]